انا لا اعرف الجهاز هذا بالضبط لكن ما
اعرفه ان بعد ان ظهر ملف التسفير وبدات
الايقافات في صفوف حركه النهضه في قيدات
حركه النهضه وغيرها من الرؤوس التي
ستفتح باب جهنم على العديد من الرؤوس في
كامل اجهزه الدوله
كانت هناك عمليه كبيره من اجل التخلص من
رئيس الجمهوريه قيس سعيد الذين يحملونه
فتح هذا الملفات يحملونه مسؤوليه فتح هذه
الملفات
واكيد انهم
من اجل التخلص منه قاموا
بتخطيط والتامر على امن الدوله من اجل
التخلص من هذا
الرئيس ومن خاصه من نظام الذي
تحصلنا عليه والنظام الجديد بعد الثوره
الشعبيه التي حدثت في 25 2021 والتي
اخرجتهم من الحكم واخرجت كل مافيا الفساد
من من قوقعتها
فخططوا للعوده
وارادوا العوده بكل السبل بكل السبل سواء
سياسيه او حتى معناها بطرق التي تهدد امن
القومي وكان السيناريوات مخيفه كانت تخطط
لتونس ولكن
المخابرات والعديد من الامنيين الشرفاء
قاموا باحباط هذا المخطط واعتقال او ايقاف
كل المتورطين في هذا المخطط